let's brown the great motivator says
people change their lives when they
finally say that's it I've had it I'm
not living like this anymore I make too
much money to be this broke that's when
you change your life when people get
that thing going in their voice you can
hear it you can see the way they set
their jaw you can see the way their eyes
look you see the way they carry
themselves they are now going to be
intentional and they're not gonna put up
with a half but mediocre life anymore
I'm gonna change my life and that's when
you do it and the neat thing is you can
just decide right now to do that ready
set go
you can just decide
marquita is gonna do it I think marki is
gonna do it that's why I gave her a
financial piece but you got to get
disgusted I mean I remember when we were
going broke and losing everything we're
in our 20s Rachel's a brand-new baby
denise is a toddler we're so broke we
couldn't pay attention we were starving
to death people calling us and screaming
at us
American Express called my house we owed
him eleven hundred and sixty six dollars
and they called my house and the
collector at American Express that's my
wife he said why would you stay with a
man that wouldn't pay his bills he was
being an abusive collector trying to get
her riled up to get the bill paid that's
what collectors do they try to feed on
your emotions she called me crying at
work thinking the same thing I got so
mad I couldn't see got told my wife she
should leave me
I got so mad I couldn't see I was ready
to go to Jacksonville Florida to the
little collection department there and
kick somebody's butt right I've got so
mad I was so illogical I paid the bill I
used our food money we didn't be food
cuz I paid stupid American Express but
you know what I did that was the stupid
thing I did you know what the positive
thing was I did I said we are never
doing business with American Express
again the rest of our lives any company
that would have someone on their
employee that acts that way I'm gonna do
no business for the American Express
what's 30 years ago
you know how much business I've done
with American Express in any form
not not period
discover car call with a single mom I
was coaching him she was in the bathroom
getting ready for work her child five
years old picked up the phone and the
collector told the child and the
Discover card was gonna come take his
toys because mama hadn't paid the bill
these are the kind of scum that work at
these places you have to have a moment
where you say I I'm putting up with this
anymore when you have that moment you'll
change your life and until then you're
just gonna be mediocre half but people
wandering around broke looking like
you're not